we're finding angles today we've
actually done a little bit this before
but we're gonna do it a little more that
bit more we got to start by having a
subheading which is before we're
fighting it goes at all I want you to
write this okay this is a really
important idea it goes all the way back
to and we're doing equations okay so
think back to equations and solving
equations in particular right now if you
have something like this simple one okay
X plus two equals three right and to
solve an equation like that what we
really want to do is find the value of
whatever that pretty really right now
we're trying to think of an equation
equal so it's kind of like a on sale
scales and it's balanced right so if you
do something to one side you do it to
the other yeah so what things should we
do to both sides here to get X by itself
and solve it we should good we should
take away 2 minus 2 for both sides
really sanofi okay now you can do that
without doing the working but just for
the sake of it I'm gonna write it the
working the -2 on both sides I can't
love you too follow that all right and
then sure enough over here the plus to
the minus 2 they just sort of cancel
each other out right so you get zero
here so it's just an X it's 3 minus 2 is
1 and that's the solution you can take
that you can pop back in your original
ok so this is example one yep
you mean this slightly 2-2 this like
yeah you mean write it out okay now the
reason why I put it on both sides is to
emphasize because this is something but
it's easy to get wrong if you do
something in one side you must do it to
both sides
right so alternatively you could go
straight to saying well look if you get
us a takeaway tooth it's gonna get rid
of this plus 2 in it so you could just
write down X that's what's gonna happen
eventually
right and say x equals 3 minus 2 but I
think it's really helpful to see you're
doing the same thing to both sides okay
yeah I like what it's like with it with
the other side you'll do much the same
thing you'll have some negatives if you
do it that way but it'll work out yeah
right now here's the import of heat
again right the reason why we chose - to
write minus 2 is exactly right is
because minus 2 is the inverse of plus 2
right so there's this important idea and
inverse right it's like a it's like a
process right for an operation or really
if you want to be really technical you
can use the word a function or function
that what it does is it reverses or
undoes something that happened before
it's literally it's like an undo button
actually right it's like look at a plus
2 it's like we hit undo the way you do
it is take away 2 right that does
something else ok
right so this inverse that is really
important so four plus two
this is we're comfortable with this the
universe is minus two right well let's
have a look at another quick example
what if I gave you three x equals 24
okay again what we've got here is
there's only one thing we need to do to
get X by itself it's alright what should
I do now to help you see what's going on
I'm gonna show you that up three X right
it's actually short here what's it short
for what's it short for three times X
right now rather than right 3 times X
I'm actually gonna write x times 3
you'll see why in a second okay because
yeah you see the operation is x 3 so the
inverse of x 3 is divided by 3 it's
exactly right just like up here I'm
gonna write as I said I'll divide by 3
if I do the left-hand side I should do
the right hand side divided by seconds
okay are you sure it's Evan hey you can
always check because I could put it back
in here three times extra enough is 24
okay don't worry sir what happened
right we had times three so we looked
for its inverse which was divided by
three okay